your surgeon will perform an abdominal
aortic aneurysm repair to prevent the
rupture of a bulging area of your aorta
the largest artery in the body is the
aorta which is attached to the heart and
receives blood directly from the left
ventricle or main pumping chamber the
aorta is divided into four parts the
ascending aorta aortic arch thoracic
aorta and the abdominal aorta the
abdominal aorta is the last and largest
section of the aorta it supplies blood
to the lower regions of your body
including the organs in the abdomen and
pelvis the abdominal aorta ends around
navel level where it splits into the two
iliac arteries that carry blood to the
legs the aorta has a thick wall so it
can withstand the high pressure of blood
being pumped from the heart over time
the wall of the aorta may weaken slowly
bulging outward like a balloon when this
condition occurs in the abdominal region
it is called an abdominal aortic
aneurysm your surgeon will perform an
open abdominal aortic aneurysm repair
when the diameter of your aorta exceeds
two inches or if you're having symptoms
such as intense abdominal pain or an
abnormally prominent abdominal pulsation
before the open procedure and IV line
will be started to provide you with
fluids antibiotics and anesthesia a
traditional open surgical repair is
performed under general anesthesia which
means you will be asleep for the
duration of the procedure a breathing
tube will be inserted through your mouth
and into your windpipe to help you
breathe during the operation when you're
asleep a catheter will be inserted into
your bladder to drain your urine and
monitor your kidney function your
surgeon will begin by making an incision
from the breastbone to below the navel
he or she will then locate the aneurysm
and clamp the aorta just above and below
it your surgeon will then open the
aneurysm
and so an artificial graft the same size
and shape as a healthy a order into
place
your surgeon will stitch the wall of the
aneurysm closed over the newly placed
graft the graft will reinforce the walls
of the aorta your surgeon will close the
abdominal incision with stitches the
total length of this procedure is
usually four to six hours your surgeon
will perform endovascular aneurysm
repair a newer minimally invasive
procedure if you have severe heart
disease or are at increased surgical
risk due to age or other medical
conditions before the endovascular
procedure as with the open procedure an
IV line will be started to provide you
with fluids and antibiotics you may
receive general anesthesia or you may
receive a sedative in an epidural or
regional anesthesia to numb only the
lower half of your body your surgeon
will begin by making a small incision in
your groin over your femoral artery then
he or she will insert a guide wire into
the artery and gently push it up toward
the site of your aneurysm
a catheter or
tube will be passed over the guidewire
and pushed toward your aneurysm using
live x-ray pictures as a guide your
surgeon will pass an endovascular stent
graft a compressed fabric and metal tube
through the catheter to the aneurysm
then he or she will open the graft which
will be held in place with metallic
hooks and stents your surgeon may insert
additional graft components to extend
the graft into the blood vessels
supplying your legs once the graft is in
place your blood will flow through it
not into the surrounding aneurysm sac
which will remove the pressure from your
aneurysm finally your surgeon will
remove the catheters and close the
incisions in your groin the procedure
will generally take two to three hours
after your procedure if you had a
breathing tube it will be removed and
you will be taken to the intensive care
unit for recovery you will receive
fluids and nutrition through your IV you
may also have a tube inserted through
your nose and into your stomach to
remove secretions until your intestines
regain normal functioning the usual
hospital stay for an open procedure is 5
to 10 days while the stay for an
endovascular procedure is usually
shorter at 2 to 3 days